today's topic we got yet another video
from the uk
and we are back with another season of
dance the shooting
foot asylum i've lined up a series of
speed dates at the end of the speed
dates the girls will pick their favorite
the person with the most points will win
i'm ready
[Music]
[Laughter]
hello
i mean i guess if we kept speaking then
maybe you might hear it but i'm
oh i said then maybe yeah
she cooked chicken correctly that's
funny they looked at her accent the way
a lot of uh
north americans look at their accent you
know what i'm saying yeah
because they're like oh my god you've
seen the sun
there you you came and it rained all the
[ __ ] time you know oh my god
are you caribbean yeah oh my god you've
seen the sun
what about you what's your background
caribbean africa jamaica oh yeah jamaica
yeah
rihanna's not even from trinidad and
tobago barbados right
something like that hey hey hey forehead
get gang that's how i remember things
hold up let me let me look her up she's
from barbados
he's from barbados
baby listen i'ma just say man rihanna's
an honorary ethiopian you know i mean
she don't even need a passport or a visa
she just flash that forehead
[ __ ] go right through customs pass go
collect 200 enjoy your time in addis
ababa
you already know what time it is what do
you mean listen you listen you know how
we're having a real estate boom
rihanna's forehead's price has gone up
are you serious you better get a
mortgage for that forehead let's [ __ ]
go
nah every time you're talking about the
capital of ethiopia
yeah it's funny it's just like if your
nickname was baba
and you was talking about rihanna's
boobie that is brianna's booty
ah this a baba
why did you say my country's name like
you were an
extra on [ __ ] coming to america
midfield
uh but you know what i will say man you
know shout out to rihanna shout out to
rihanna for real for real like uh
i i never listened to her her music you
know sun panda replays the last song i
listened to
and i'm grateful for that but you know i
mean i'm just happy to see people shine
you know when they're part of the
forehead trap it feels good for me
it makes me believe i can achieve things
in life and
don't let your forehead hold you back
all right all you people with bangs
all you people getting baby baby hair to
try to hide all that real estate that
you got
maybe people like a front yard okay
okay they like it when you got so much
forehead you ain't got no backhead you
understand what i'm saying
it's okay embrace it embrace all of this
imagine a big
word and in the back just neck
you just made no sense
you have so much from your forehead you
ain't got no backhand it's just like
big ass bob in the front and a
you damn right let's go yo rihanna's
forehead is not a joke god bless her
hold up let me look at a picture you
look good i don't give a [ __ ] about that
forehead
no no i do not care she looked gooder
than a [ __ ] no that's photoshop
these [ __ ]
are dirty to be fair
i've had i've had photoshop pictures of
my forehead too it's just part of the
game
i don't even know what the big deal is
or for it could be as big as a photoshop
one right there i i'm gonna give a [ __ ]
yeah her forehead could be as big as it
wants as long as he doesn't shine bright
like a diamond we're good to go
okay you did you know it's funny that
rihanna made a whole song about
umbrellas like
do i need one okay let's keep it a book
rihanna just have to walk like this
she just gotta walk her left thank you
you come to trinidad with me one day
yes i heard the carnival's lit i just
want to say next month i'm going are you
busy next month yeah
no you know i'm definitely due to pull
up you know you guys had a song i think
the freak of the week so we thank you
right what do you mean i think you have
a song freak of the week
and then maybe one percent chance of
being from djibouti
yo listen if you hear wallahi sometimes
even adding an extra letter
but it's not even a word it's like i
swear to god but super saiyan you
understand they go well
there's like three layers you know what
i'm saying
what
that's what it is if i hear wallahi come
out of a man's mouth
i just know there's a somalian and
normally they never come solo they
always come in groups
listen if you see one somalian just
assume there's more
somewhere hiding nearby okay do not
fight one of them because one of them
will pop out a trash can and sucker
punch they don't play
all right they might be a little bit
skinnier and smaller but them man
they hold it down tribal doesn't matter
where they go that's how they call each
other
you know what i mean you know how
batman's got the bad light they got the
wallahi like they just
just [ __ ] [ __ ] assemble okay
once you're covered in paint and stuff
you're not worried about oh i want to
look cute for kunan because he's passing
by
conan has more than his face i have more
than my face you know we're just going
to have a good time
oh wow she came from china too
i'm going to give you a hug no i'm
definitely going to come to the
yeah yeah i'm going to pull up here hold
up enjoy
take care darling
[Applause]
they exposed them so fast and he he was
very respectful
he just did a quick glance like the
confirmation glance you know what that
one
yeah you know what i mean it's like
pretend you're doing something
that's amateur but it's it's all right
it works what's the next level
wear sunglasses
just wear sunglasses bro what are you
talking about
with your glasses [ __ ] but you know you
know the thing though
i like getting caught
[Applause]
[Music]
i hope so
is she the one i hope so
[Music]
do you think you're going to get caught
abba
today's video is sponsored by surf shark
vpn
so vpn is basically an application or
web extension that you could use on your
web browser or on your internet
to mask your ip address basically hiding
your location
from whatever website you're interacting
with now you might think
why would i want to hide where i'm at it
doesn't matter well unfortunately there
are places that block you
based off of your ip address and so if
you're trying to view
online content on let's download certain
things based off where you live
those things could be restricted now i
like watching tv shows
feel me sometimes they're foreign feel
me and
when that happens basically i use a vpn
to be able to bypass that so i can watch
what i want to watch because i feel like
the internet's at its best
when everything's accessible if you use
promo code abba and preach
you get 83 off plus three months free
so take advantage of the deal watch what
you want to watch and don't be
restricted by anyone's barriers
you deserve to go wherever you like you
guys
hate us you hate our music you're like
oh let's jump on down to music let's not
be
what is that for i'm like to be happy
though y'all just want a dog
on the floor all that kind of nonsense
i'll marry our accent put a ring on it
you guys hate soccer but you're always
an accountable yeah oh
my god spit in fact jamaica cannot no i
mean i didn't
want to dance you know oh man ah dance
batman not ants
and then everybody's in the carnival and
[ __ ] you're always at the carnival and
[ __ ] stop
yo she's pitting facts right there y'all
talking [ __ ] about carnival
if you can't wait till you reach these
that is
the nation of mascara and then you don't
want to hear it but you're there
whenever you go to parties jamaicans are
going inside whenever it's soca and let
all the girls then all the guys that dig
soccer dance and then they just want to
hear some
like they want to hear something about
lick shot you know what i mean i want to
hear about
you know y'all want to hear about
uh you know i mean they want to hear
about all that
themselves and [ __ ] [ __ ] it's a bedroom
i fear
you know what i mean they want to hear
about all that [ __ ]
put up your pants and pull it on your
waist and tuck in your shirt and
don't bleach your face but they don't
want to hear no soca but when carnival
hits you're all
up in there come on man you know you
love soccer stop talking
stop talking or maybe they just like the
scene and all the ladies
they love so there's a reason there's a
reason why all the parties they allow
women to come in for free men gotta pay
because men will go wherever the ladies
go
if there's enough women [ __ ] i'll show
up to a country club it could be a clan
meeting if there's some fat
asses in there i'd be like hey [ __ ]
burn the cross in the back let me let me
just finish this song with
shorty you know what i mean all right
because right now sean paul is playing
we be burning y'all be burning back
there we be doing our thing over here
you feel me
stop playing with me he had soccer but
you love our women right so what's that
you kind of have to love what comes with
the woman what'd i tell you [ __ ]
i swear to god no no no no [ __ ] that
timing was perfect wasn't it don't even
play with me yeah
i don't know your [ __ ] yo yo i don't
know who this girl is
apparently her name is lay she's amazing
that's what she is hey
hey egg if you try to lay on me you know
i'm saying if you're trying to lay
together somewhere or maybe we just lay
in the grass you know what i mean
check out the the clouds yo what's up
holla at your boy she's amazing
okay live your life i might not be from
barbados
okay but you know what i mean as a
descendant of highly celestia you know
us and the people from the caribbean
we got a bit of a connection literally
me and rihanna forehead let's go
wow
oh my gosh listen to me this teeth oh my
gosh yeah
that's bad everything your confidence is
amazing is it come closer baby oh my
gosh
you're moving much
that is hey definition of
real cassava come closer roll it y'all
boy rolly dal
why don't you do that one then why she
wrapped his why she got to look around
him wouldn't you
[ __ ] you he put it
he put it in his face
don't tell me you've come here looking
for a relationship first and foremost is
that not what you want
babes
i'm done is it guy no fly that's
straight away what's that
their legs went round is that wrong no
we can have like nice moments
all right yeah and you could be mine for
like monday tuesday somebody else's
wednesday thursday
no no no no i could be yours monday
tuesday and then studio wednesday
thursday
friday then mom saturday sunday the new
monday tuesday again that's all right i
could show you with mom the legs around
the thing
confirmed she's a freaking week
so your fault son or not i am okay so
[Applause]
there's something that happens when you
pick up a lady off the ground
especially if it's a thick girl a big
gala one girl
you know especially if she got a little
bit of thing around the ball
when you pick the girl off the ground
and you show where you could toss her
around it does
something to a woman i don't know and i
can't explain but i've seen
the benefits of it there's something
that happened when you pick
a lady that thinks she can
be picked up
and this is what you're witnessing right
now
so
and you can squat it yo listen listen me
listen there's a there's a song there's
a soccer song
pick up something anything
run with it start run with it when they
hear that song you have to
you have to pick someone and start to
run with them or speak anything and
you take your when you look at the
biggest gianlinadi
and you look at her you know you know
what i'm you know what you have to do
but i have to pick you off the ground
and you'll pick her up
and you quote her like it's nothing me
not here
if you're 350 pounds
now pick you off the ground yeah squad
yeah
they put you right back now and after
that go take a drink
yeah i want a drink let's drink god
there's something in here
yes all right man listen listen holler
at you boy you can get it all
don't get me wrong my lips game is mad
but not right now yeah not right now let
me do this from now before i forget put
the number in
the left or not okay no problem delete
my whole thing
[Music]
i saw this coming on the humble thing i
was humble why
though because she's talking about wow
look at me we'll make really nice kids
yeah i will keep them monday tuesday you
can have them wednesday no you're mad if
we're getting kids you think i'm a
monday tuesday done
you're violating i'm the everyday week
yeah i'm up to feed my youth
that's gonna hold it to the boot for me
yeah guys
guys if you think she's posted it just
call it and if it's awkward don't be mad
at her
just walk away but if it's real you wish
we don't have our phones on here
what
[Applause]
that's the wrong one
that's the face of a woman who's been
cut i suspected it just because the way
she was looking at the camera when she
was typing i'm like okay
oh yeah you're all right i told you he's
got what he's got circumference
that's the point you can hold here like
i lift him and just like that and yeah
balance him
oh okay don't make me drop right there
hurting
i do like a lot of like japanese culture
as well oh
you know what i want to go tokyo badly
you know oh there's another one of the
boy ones there's a conandy
[Applause]
i actually do like a relationship but
i'm a girl i like to have fun as well so
i think um
guys tend to be a bit intimidated by
that you know like in what way can you
tell me just
like we're talking like in the bedroom
or every way that needs to be
seen like yeah in any way possible in
any way that's necessary i'll go on a
date with someone who's really old
is it yeah how do you how old am i yeah
21 21
how old are you yo 621 yo my apologies
yo listen
forget everything i said about yo this
girl hitting me up for anything
21. she's not 21.
she's not 21. that's what she said nice
to meet you
smile but i felt like maybe he took me a
little too seriously
i took her serious for that with the
number
she gave me the wrong number basically
trying to say like yeah you you threw a
few series
i thought you were saying like you're
not you're getting don't do that hear
what i'm saying
it's different now if you haven't shown
me that side i'm not going to pick you
up
i think he doesn't want to lift you but
the girl wanted to suck up my face
now i don't even like you that you know
that's paul from you gal advice for you
out there
if you're not on it don't move like
you're on it this man was pressed
chicken pressed don't move like you're
on it
you're moving mad my date with conan
went well as well
first i felt like he was very nervous
like reserved he wasn't really saying
much but also i do like a guy with a bit
of mystery i can tell he's really sweet
as well and gentlemanly so
i'll tell you that one next time but i
am
[Laughter]
i think nothing was like no i don't know
you just need you need to duck
but it's minor man don't go boosters
here we go my dear jordan who's jordan
again
but but why are you surprised oh hold on
hold on hold on
bro she left the table you said you were
bored
if you said she was you was bored maybe
the feeling was mutual so
she was just being blunt and honest
about this [ __ ] it's like
you didn't really say anything and your
thing was very
flat lined you flatlined that bruh what
is
so you can't be surprised by it why you
might
it's it's like you can't be surprised by
it
you said you was bored let's start
confidence i love
when you're not humble with it i despise
it especially when it doesn't add up
okay why you want he want cocky
you have tesco finest ego and you have
tesco value face
scared him okay so so this is this is
one of those things
okay and i'm gonna just get to a little
bit more of a serious book because this
is on television
people act different right on television
people want to portray themselves
certain type of way so they're going to
say oh i'm into this guy and i would
never go for this guy
and you know when you come in and you
look good sometimes people will
overcompensate and try to be
extra or they'll infer things like based
off the footage that we saw i don't know
if they edited something out
he didn't really say much it was just a
boring date but because he's a
attractive looking dude you already come
at it with a different energy the same
way
you know what i'm saying if i was an
attractive girl right and she rejected
me
some guys would look at they'd be like
oh [ __ ] you think you're too good for
me because you are nine or whatever
you think nice she did the same thing
she said the same thing
and look he might be an arrogant person
i'm just saying based off the date that
we saw there was none of that so
that's just one thing i wanted to say
what was that response
maybe he said yeah maybe he said some
[ __ ] but there was the
moesa again you know editing there's
nothing that we saw that was like so
much
arrogant about it except his good looks
[ __ ] are gonna step in with the
good looks you're going to be you're
going to see the lights came
off up with the good looks and they're
going to be like you know what yeah
nice right from that people judge right
from the back people say
we don't just y'all judge all right stop
it knock it off
everybody's going to be like yeah but i
don't shut up shut your whole mouth up
we all judge now that being said we all
just on different things
and you see that man go in you think
he's nice
if he's not playing like that he's too
serious oh he takes himself too
seriously because he thinks he's nice
yeah but maybe maybe it's not that maybe
we saw
there's something else but not from what
i saw
yeah yeah i think this is one of those
clout moments in my opinion
there's one of those things rather i get
to show him up on on the screen so i'm
not going to miss my shot you know what
i'm saying so yeah
so my favorite dates it's between
whatever chunks conan and
chunks they both got me because i like
to dance dance
that's all you do is sing brother it's
actually jaron i didn't think about that
i think you one day
cool bro i would say two of them if i'm
allowed
she's not saying that [ __ ] i say stole
me oh
my backs my legs
i'm not allowed listen i'm not fighting
no guild over no man so i'll go with
kona
i've got one come on bro i'm not
fighting over and over and over you
can't go with the game i think i'm going
to get the last one as well you know
not that i don't even want to watch you
no more man i'm sick of it wow
hey listen you might be loud but he's a
he's a hilarious sore loser i love that
you know what i'm saying some people are
salty they don't hide it this
[ __ ] does not hide the salt
he's high blood pressure yes
[Music]
you know when they say high blood
pressure runs in the families because
they got a kid like this man
yo he's a high blood pressure right
there
oh that's funny but anyways you know
what i enjoyed this it was
it was it was fun to watch it was
interesting it was interesting we
definitely had some good laughs there
the girl was uh definitely definitely
cool except for the last part i thought
she was awesome so that's pretty much
all i got you got anything else
nah man it's pretty fun it was
entertaining there you go
these guys are fun you guys are funny
yeah if you guys like this kind of stuff
we cover more uk content
that'll be up on the patreon so if you
want to see more of our takes there you
can go check that out
as well as other bonus videos that we do
over there but yeah if you guys want to
see more of this stuff leave comments
leave
likes do all that good stuff because we
will cover more of these videos
and that is it for today's video
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
you